you like some lemonade I would like some
lemonade are you selling any yes okay
well then I want some my friend one so
let's see how this is your first sale
yes it is what's your name Buddy Andrew
Andrew all right pink lemonade all right
that's the good
stuff no you got to give him more oh you
got a that's that's that's good that's
good I like that kind of and then give
that to him all right how much $1 okay
well I'm going to give you 20 is that
okay yeah we got some change no no you
keep the change oh my goodness what do
you say thank you you're welcome thank
you so much bro this is delicious you
made this you or Mom tell the truth we
kind of work together you're a team yeah
all right thank you buddy have the best
day